[Musique]
oui mais n'est pas rien même si ces
mises à mal depuis cette semaine on va
parler de nouvelles qui font la
manchette mais qui deviennent un sujet
ça veut dire la reconnaissance de
territoire non c'est pourquoi le
programme vague dont on va parler c'est
le canadien qui va reconnaître qu'il est
un territoire non cvs canet avec un pont
des matches où le câble et la deuxième
nouvelle et bien c'est concernant le
gouvernement du nouveau brunswick qui
ont envoyé un mémo pour demander aux
employés de ne plus faire de
reconnaissance de territoire en nommant
particulièrement les efforts non c'est
mais on leur dit qu'ils seront pas punis
s'ils le font pourquoi ces deux
nouvelles loges pour la manche est bien
passé raison non seulement des
implications sociales historiques mais
aussi politique et légale présentement
dans une concernant une des deux
nouvelles on va commencer que les
canadiens parce que le canadien on
s'entend s'implique beaucoup d'avenir
mans par rapport au sport dans les
communautés de temps avec leurs
fondations leur gardien de but carey
price qui est
programmation donne un peu l'impression
que justement c'est quelque chose qui
doit emmener p on sait qu'avec la
découverte des corps des enfants sur les
anciens terrains des pensionnats il ya
la lumi quelque chose au sein des
citoyens au sein des organismes de
pouvoir redonner aux communautés
autochtones justement cette visibilité
que longtemps manqué dans notre relation
de dons en reconnaissant qu on est en
territoire n'ont cédé autochtone pour
beaucoup de citoyens c'est une manière
de remettre le nom des nations étaient
présentes dans la bouche et dans
l'esprit des gens c'est une manière de
remettre l'histoire dans la veille déjà
donc en transmettant l'histoire on faire
réapparaître les nations en les nommant
tous les deux sans trois mois non ces
pays distincts viennent d'erreurs parce
que c'est le nom qui vient de la langue
cavigal donc c'est un geste est très
puissant qui est très unificateur
d'ailleurs ils m'ont donné envie de
m'acheter
parce que justement enfin quelque chose
qui nous représente sans devenir
l'équipe autochtone ça devient une
équipe qui porteuse d'une réconciliation
entre les citoyens autochtones et non
pour moi ce geste là à une implication
qui dort au niveau citoyens au niveau
des individus
est une réconciliation c'est par rapport
à lundi civilisation donc ça c'est l'un
des aspects de la reconnaissance
territoriale
par rapport aux reconnaissances
territoriale souvent d'individus mon nom
est ce qu'on peut faire un moyen diminue
dit oui moi ce que je fais comme un
vêtement je suis en territoire non cvs à
binic et web anaky alors quand je le
fais c'est que je reconnais que je suis
sur un territoire qui historiquement pas
le mien pour que famille nous et je
reconnais que la connaissance que les
oies benaki et les abénakis ont sur leur
propre territoire sublime toute
connaissance que j'ai sur ce territoire
dont jeune fille alors connaissant jeune
fille l histoire je me fis alors savoir
sur les ressources qui sont présentes
sur les relations comme on doit tous et
comme je suis une invitée sur leur
territoire mais a tenté la même
responsabilité de protéger tétouan
m'assurer que tout le monde est
respectée c'est comme ça que j'adhère un
protocole qui vient de cette nation là
donc c'est super important pour moi
parce que si j'étais en territoire innu
et qu'on respectait pas les protocoles
les manières de faire de nous c'est
certain que c'est comme l'attesté chez
nous je sais comment fonctionne la rue
que je sais comment fonctionne la
rivière c'est la même idée c'est de dire
on ne sait savoir là pour un meilleur
vivre ensemble donc avant que citoyen ça
ne venait pas qui est important de
béquilles pas le même que par exemple si
on arrive dans des organismes comme
celui d'enghien et que le saviez unir
beaucoup plus de voix puisque c'est
quelque chose qui unifie un peu comme
beaucoup d'organismes de foncer dans
l'esprit de notre organisme sont ouverts
cette manière de faire donc ça annonce
quelque chose de très unificateur et qui
peut en plus touché des gens dans ce
cercle rassembleur et lequel interne
énorme cercle rassemblant qui va
permettre de faire coller dans d'autres
milieux que celui autochtone ou celui
des personnes qui sont concernées qui
savent qu'est ce que c'est et qui sont
touchés par le sujet ton c'est un geste
et tiga temps et nord
l'argent dans une problématique
historique parce que le 1 et critique
par rapport à celui du canadien c'est
qu'on n'est pas uniquement victoire mme
horrocks non cp ce et est historiquement
un territoire à gongué donc il ya cette
compréhension mais aussi de l'histoire
qui est très longue à avoir c'est oui on
est est un territoire à conques un mail
à venir que les cathos ans ont reconnu
présentement c'est justement du concept
de la sédentarisation forcée dans qui on
ne s'éternise et au tour de morgane
c'est les communautés mora et donc ça
driver territoire mohawk non céder parce
qu'ils utilisaient qu'elle doit on mais
ils n'étaient pas les uniques
utilisateurs du territoire donc ces
reconnaissances de territoire le qui
sont faites de sfx ça vient quand même
l'idée que c'est d'aider les pratiques
de ces d'organisation et donc on
reconnaît - justement les multiples
nation qui habitait sur de multiples
territoires et ils savent bien mais quid
et de la possession du territoire et de
la pratique sur le territoire dont c'est
sûr que moi par le passé d'utiliser
beaucoup moins à cause justement de
cette situation de sédentarisation
forcée mais j'utilise aussi beaucoup
maintenant en territoire autochtone non
cédées et je reconnais cet outil
pratique qui sont faites dessus dont je
connais l'histoire
des algonquins sur le téléthon je
reconnais même que c'est pour les
animations débutent à mort qui était de
passage à montréal donc on reconnaît
aussi que c'est un territoire de passage
ce territoire des changes et ça permet
aussi aux communautés qui sont dans
cette vidéo de territoire s'est dénoncé
des de se rappeler que par le passé il y
avait encore plus une plus grande
fluidité des mouvements et il n'y avait
pas une fixation de territoires comme
c'est fait aujourd'hui avec les réserves
avec quelques victoires avec les
les frontières qui sont fixes parce
qu'elles ont été décidées de façon fixe
mais ne l'était pas qu'on vivait sur le
territoire quand il y avait une pratique
libre sur des droits alors comprenez
historiquement la seine des boss était
une mauvaise de turgot qu'un mais ça ça
vient tout d'un concept de recentrer
très institutionnelle du concept de qui
est propriétaire du territoire alors que
l'on parlait de pratiques et de savoir
sur le téléthon
voyez comment ça fait c'est l'âge comme
sujet et là j'arrive au nouveau
brunswick parce que c'est quand même le
ministre de la justice qui a envoyé ce
mémo la aux employés et pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont présentement justement en
cours pour pouvoir défendre le fait que
les communautés qui sont un territoire
non céder parce qu'ils ont fait un
traité mais après des pépins traité ou
et celle des territoires eux réclament
en cours justement 60% des territoires
parce qu'ils sont non céder donc quand
sa vie politique conseiller du
gouvernement le l'implication pourront
de illégale en territoire n'ont cédé
scanzi c'est la vérité c'était des
territoires c'est d'ailleurs au québec
beaucoup de terrain dans son concept
dans d'autres communautés il ya des
traités mais c'est pas des traités qui
s'est délitée le toit des traités de
partage du territoire dans le fond on
chasse on s'inquiète pas les autres sur
les options et p il faut calculer comme
ils ont cédé le territoire c'est pas ça
mais at elle doit annoncer des sites ya
même pas de titre qui a été émis pour
céder environ donne les territoires
alors quand avait maintenant c'est comme
si on était face au gouvernement la
vérité de l'histoire légale des
territoires autres et leur embarras loi
sur les invités la loi sur les indiens
étaient mises en tutelle des communautés
adaptant alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand même longtemps dit elle on prend
les choses on doit les gérer pour toi et
qu'en tu seras major jeudi date de
l'année et toutes les baies la loi sont
les uns étaient présentement c'est ok on
m'enlevait la loi sur les uns étaient
ils seront plus des mineurs aux yeux de
la loi mais quand tu enlèves cette loi
leur est ce que tu donnes des
territoires qui était justement mis en
doute est-ce que tu redonnes le droit à
l'auto gouvernance et communautés
d'accueil avait avant que cette loi ne
sont imposés sur les communautés
autochtones ça coûterait des milliards
de dollars au gouvernement canadien
d'enlever cette voie là s'il faisait
dans ce processus qui était juste quitté
légal donc présentement de fin est tirée
la loi sur les high tech france télécom
nos contacts en oublie même qu'ils aient
fait si tu l'avais territoire et le type
nas est réussie parce qu'on a une
conversation à deux vitesses inc ses
premiers pas et l'autre que c'était
gardien du territoire qui étaient des
gestionnaires de territoires mais pour
que les ressources soient mis le maire
et toute cette conversation le se faire
autour de deux systèmes qui sont
différents avec la loi sur les indiens
wissam ans on peut l'effacer comme le
grand livre l'avait prévu et qu on vous
faisait de toutes les options des
citoyens canadiens mais il ya des titres
qui suivent sélective ancestraux
autochtone qui sont tenues en
communautés qui sont tenus légalement on
semble parler haut et pas par des actes
il dit d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on a
vu que sur un peu grands hypers en place
voulait faciliter le droit de propriété
des individus autochtone de mon avis
c'est une bonne chose une bonne chose
non parce que ça efface le droit
ancestral du groupe la communauté est ce
qui fait que justement plus d'avoir des
individus qui veulent quelque chose ben
sensation du bien-être de tous
l'ensemble du groupe et ça c'est venu
vraiment aidé à ne pas perdre ses droits
ce trouble en tant que communauté
autochtone donc le nouveau produit que
les poignets entravés les corses parce
que reconnaître justement l'histoire
départ à l'action si on s'y reconnaît le
fait qu'il
ait canada n'a pas été un état de droit
pour les programmations plutôt un état
colonisateur et ça c'est difficile
d'avoir cette conversation là d'ailleurs
une des choses qui m'a pourquoi utiliser
au tour de reconnaissance territoriale
c'est la quantité énorme de commentaire
ainsi c'est désobligeant en dessous des
articles de nouvelles sur les réseaux
sociaux et le vivre ni au paquet 15
parce que on parle beaucoup présentement
de reconnaître le territoire autochtone
mais il ya une répression sida de la
colonisation française le sait que c'est
de dire
on reconnaît qu'on est avec toi autant
de mets pas vraiment c'est juste c'est
vrai que c'est un instrument mais le 2
août juste avant qu'on ait colonisé par
les français mais c'est utilisé en plus
pourquoi réaffirmé dès fois d'identité
française la nouvelle france l'identité
québécoise hélène ironie énorme quand on
ne pourra connaître justement cette
souveraineté et je n'ai pas su arrêter
avec une couronne jeudi sa droite d'edel
sur son territoire et d'exister dans sa
lente qui n'est pas reconnu par ces
groupes le pour pouvoir ensuite allée du
décompte ce qu'on nous ont colonisés en
anglais donc plusieurs niveaux
historiques plusieurs niveaux discussion
autant au niveau de reconnaître d
invisibilité que de reconnaître et de
redonner aux terribles était le corps
aux communautés de compenser pas
uniquement en argent quelques décennies
plus tard mais vraiment de compenser la
douleur les pratiques qui ont des fêtes
justement que le bris de ces traités
d'amis thil qui ont amené à les
politiques telles que la loi sur les
internes on reconnaît un vêtement c'est
la première étape de reconnaître
justement l'inconfort de comment le
canada était construit comment le québec
a été construit sur des territoires
n'ont cédé sur les très dynamiques sur
big man donc vous comprendrez que ce ne
sera pas facile voire un croc regard sur
soi même la flore de la réconciliation
mais pas la réconciliation à tout prix
ses segments constitution dans les
prochaines décennies est justement l oit
sur les intérêts seront retirés et ne
seront offertes dans un effacement de
l'histoire on a corrigé les rangs c'est
vraiment qu'il va y avoir quelque chose
qui va être donnée aux communautés et
c'est ce droit à l'autodétermination
qu'on a depuis les premiers contacts
avec les européens alors super
passionnant cette conversation le met
très compliqué et à plusieurs niveaux
je dirais que ce qui montre beaucoup que
un problème c'est vraiment la réactivité
des gens face à une reconnaissance du
territoire et de là on va voir justement
le malaise qui existe entre à gradation
d'actonel octobre qui est basée
justement
le bail des territoires sont les
la sédentarisation forcée sur des
concepts qui ont été déposées et que
maintenant une autochtone nouvelles des
femmes pour avoir une discussion qui est
juste pour avoir une reconnaissance
aussi qui n'est pas basée uniquement sur
plaire à l'autre mais vraiment de
respect mutuel de nation à nation alors
gros sujet je souhaite une bonne semaine
j'espère que vous hésitez pas à nous
envoyer des questions j'espère aussi que
vous serez capable de départ dans ces
énoncés en jeu de façon
rester respectueux envers les nations
autochtones au revoir